the dinosaurs in Jurassic Park are
fearsome and agile but how lifelike are
their movements as they found after that
prey researchers at the University of
California Berkeley are finding clues in
the way geckos and lizards get around so
in our lab we're curious about how
animals move and one of the interesting
things is that they have tails and so
previously we discovered amazing things
that geckos could do with their tails
when they fall from a leaf they can
write themselves they use it when
they're climbing and so we wondered what
happens when they run along the ground
or when lizards actually leap into the
air so the reason why you picked these
pretty little is is because we were
interested in it an animal that was good
at navigating a lot of terrain so the
experiment was inspired in part by eye
studies that we did in geckos which are
arboreal in living the tops of trees in
the canopy we wanted to see how this
kind of behavior could enable locomotion
over rough terrain on the ground
we had red headed African lizards run
along a track and actually Vault off a
box much like you would see in the
Olympics but instead of landing on the
ground they would move towards a wall
and land on the wall with a shelter on
top we were curious about what they did
with respect to keeping their body
stable when they jumped on the vault we
made it so that sometimes they didn't
slip and they just jumped right to the
wall and other times they slipped and
their body would start to rotate forward
and what we discovered was that that
energy and rotating forward could be
redirected to the tail so they didn't
know his dive into the wall and they
landed stabili to best understand what
the animals were doing not only did we
make a mathematical model but we made a
physical model a robot we mimic what the
lizards were doing by having the robot
go off a ramp as if it was jumping like
the animal
and we had it not use its tail and just
crash into the wall and then we had a
controller on it like you would in
engineering so that as the body attitude
would start to nose down the tail would
compensate to keep it stable it turns
out that one of the first guesses about
how tails are used came from a
paleontologist over 40 years ago he
suggested that in theropod dinosaurs the
tails may be used as an act of
stabilizer and so we wondered whether or
not we could take our data and model a
theropod dinosaur like Velociraptor
shown here to see how effective a tail
might be we actually compared it then to
both the robot and our lizards and found
that if it could actually move its tail
and it had the muscles capable of doing
it the tail could be even more effective
than our lizards we wondered whether or
not the makers of Jurassic Park got it
right so we looked back at the film and
sure enough there was one scene where
Velociraptor jumps from the balcony and
if you look carefully you'll see it
moves its tail in a similar way that we
discovered in the lizards
you
you